Lee: Korean waters are
very dark and very cold.
People don't usually dive there
for fun, but I do.
The water is calm today,
and we're going to do
a wreck dive.
It looks so dangerous,
but once your eyes get used
to the environment
and you realize that things
are moving,
it's a really great joy
watching them.
I saw a fish, like, this big,
and just absolutely amazing.
Then I find a bunch of stuff
that I never expected
to find there,
like instant coffee cups,
flip flops.
It's upsetting.
We have to think about
preserving the ocean.
Diving into the water just
completely disconnects me
from the world I live in;
with 20 million people
living around the city.
It gives me a sense
of reconnection with nature.